er hat 3% des deutschen Jahres Bedarfs
seit heute hat Deutschland den gasdeal
mit Katar lange wurde darum gerungen ab
2026 geht es los Laufzeit 15 Jahre 15
Jahre ist super das sagte
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck wegen
der geplanten Klimaneutralität in
Deutschland ab 2045 müssten dann die
Mengen hinten raus aber immer geringer
werden bis dahin sind wir angewiesen auf
neue Handelspartner beim Gas darüber
wollen wir jetzt sprechen hier mit
meinen Gästen Herr stresser wie
erleichtert ist die Bundesregierung über
diesen Deal also für diesen Winter
bringt sie jetzt erstmal noch nichts
also wir werden jetzt sicher nicht
allein mit dem katarischen Gas unsere
Energieversorgung lösen aber es zeigt
schon dass wir Schritt für Schritt uns
auch unabhängig machen von Russland eine
Abhängigkeit die die letzten Jahre
Bundesregierungen Sehnen Auges
herbeigeführt haben und deswegen ist das
ein Schritt von vielen wir haben jetzt
gezeigt mit der planungsbeschleunigung
dass Deutschland ist auch kann in von
sechs Monaten lng-terminist zu bauen wer
hätte das gedacht und von dem her ist es
ein mosaik-teil in einem großen Bild
dass wir gerade bauen Mosa
ik ist ja klein es werden jetzt vor
allem auch im Vorfeld auch bei der WM
immer wieder Herr höffgen natürlich viel
Kritik gehört wir erinnern uns alle auch
wie tief sich Robert Habeck dort
verbeugt hat kann man da auch von so
einer Art Doppelmoral sprechen tut
Deutschland dann doch für Gas irgendwie
alles ja ich muss sagen die Diskussion
finde ich ja langweilig weil Energie ist
weltweit knapp da kann man sich keinen
Moralapostel tun sage ich mal leisten
Energie woher sie auch immer kommt geht
weg weil alle Länder brauchen was Katar
was auch Saudi Arabien was auch Russland
nun mal so auf hat und verkauft deswegen
ist glaube ich die Doppelmoral nicht
zielführend zielführend da ist die
Debatte wie kommen wir da raus und da
hat Robert Harbeck einige bessere
Antworten würde ich sagen als die
Vorgänger Regierungen darauf kommen wir
auch gleich noch im Detail welche
Antworten ist überhaupt im großen Thema
Energie gibt hey gut wie sehen sie
diesen de jetzt im Winter naja erstmal
nichts 15 Jahre dauert es wie sehen sie
diesen Deal kann man das als
erfolgreichen kleinen Mosaikstein in
einem gesamten Film
ich staune schon was da abgeht ich weiß
nicht ob Deutschland Weltmeister wird
auf dem Rasen aber Deutschland ist jetzt
schon Weltmeister da Heuchelei was ist
unglaublich wie man da jetzt ja Zitat
sich Bückling gemacht aber gleichzeitig
mit dem Zeigefinger auf die ganze Welt
zeigt also es zeigt aber neben dieser
Doppel durchaus ein Thema ist weil es
ist eine und es ist wirklich
heuchlerisch zeigt natürlich auch dass
die ganze Energie Strategie in sich
nicht funktioniert ich meine wir holen
jetzt Gas man will von Gas und Öl Weg
gleichzeitig feiert man das wenn das
dann soweit ist in Deutschland sind die
Kohlekraftwerke wieder hochgefahren
worden als das ist alles ein Scheitern
nicht nur zurückzuführen auf den Ukraine
Krieg sondern eben auch auf eine völlig
verfehlte Energie auch das gleiche Thema
tiefer eintauchen Frau jung wie bemerken
sie das im Alltag auch als Apothekerin
aber auch einfach ist Bürgerin macht
sich das schon bemerkbar bei Ihnen die
steigenden Energiepreise spüren Sie die
sicherlich haben wir schon steigend
Energiepreise unsere Zulieferer zum
Beispiel die mit uns zusammenarbeiten
haben
energiepreiserhöhung in unsere Kondition
mit eingepreist sei es nun der
Großhandel oder Subunternehmer
blisterzentrum oder sowas überall
bekommen wir das natürlich auch zu
spüren in der Apotheke nichtsdestotrotz
auch die
Strompreise da läuft doch der Strom auch
durch sie haben doch sicher auch
Medikamente die gekühlt werden müssen
das hat sicherlich Auswirkungen wir
haben so viele Technik mittlerweile in
der Apotheke also ich habe zwei
Apotheken die vollautomatisiert sind das
heißt wähle arbeiten mit lagerautomaten
die Medikamente sind 24 Stunden rund um
die Uhr klimatisiert ja und wenn der
Strom ausfällt dann fällt mir nichts
weiter ein als den Schlüssel rumdrehen
und das Licht auszumachen
das also worauf stellen sie sich da
schon ein wenn sie sagen wenn der Strom
mal ausfällt jetzt im Moment ist er ja
da wir hoffen alle dass es so bleibt
machen sie sich da ganz konkret auch
sorgen dass man Apotheken gar nicht
halten kann dass sie dann sagen ich hole
vielleicht noch die Medikamente raus die
ich irgendwie im Kühlschrank packen kann
haben sie solche Szenarien über
überhaupt also ich habe die schon sehr
oft durchgesprochen mit meinem Team und
aber auch zu Hause letztendlich gibt es
einfach keine Lösung weil wir sind so
abhängig von diesen Strom Lieferung dass
wir auch mittlerweile dann wirklich
nicht mehr arbeiten können sie können
keine Rezepte mehr bearbeiten sie können
keine Artikel mehr aus dem
lagerautomaten holen man müsste es
überlisten organisieren ich glaube es
ist schlichtweg unmöglich und ich hoffe
dass wenn ein Stromausfall kommt wir
hatten schon mal ein dass wir dann
einfach nach zwei Stunden wieder im Netz
sind und dann ist alles okay also sie
haben sich extra Notstromaggregate womit
sie irgendwie überbrücken können sondern
auch sonst wirklich auf jeden Fall auf
jede Stunde auf jede Minute an also auch
diese themat jetzt haben wir schon
ausdiskutiert aber stellen Sie ein
Notstromaggregat hin welche Größe muss
das sein um die ganze Technik am Laufen
zu halten sie können damit vielleicht
maximal eine Kasse noch hochfahren und
vielleicht noch den Computer
runterfahren und das war's also naja es
wird dramatisch fürchten sie das die
Kasse ist ja so das eine aber man fragt
sich was passiert mit Medikamenten also
ich kenne mich nicht so gut aus wie
lange die gekühlt wie lange bestimmte
vielleicht auch notwendige Medikamente
auskommen können ohne dass sie genau auf
der Temperatur ist also sie müssen
bedenken wir haben Medikamenten
Kühlschrank die sind alle über einen
Akku Betrieb gesichert aber auch das
reicht vielleicht für sechs Stunden und
dann muss ich die zwei damit nach Hause
nehmen ja oder wegschmeißen